[Musique]
alors bonsoir à la planète on va élargir
cette écran de télévision on est dans la
radio après tout voici toute l'équipe on
retrouve à ma gauche à ma droite ça
dépend d'où vous regardez
il a l'habitude de
l'autre côté de la planète c'est à la
gauche alors voici Léo gimelo bonjour
Léo bonjour je suis très très touché
vous avez commencé à
11h11 secondes
d'Air Canada dès que ça part attends
j'ai de l'argent dans mes poches Samir
ben bonjour bonjour Stéphane bonjour
l'équipe ça fait longtemps que vous avez
prévu Paloma à vos côtés
de Paloma de la Senorita Paloma alors
côté ensemble il y a beaucoup
d'intelligence peu de savoir autour de
cette table
on est là pour apprendre
on a un invité extraordinaire
aujourd'hui qui a tant en ligne il va
être avec nous d'ici 5 6 minutes pour
discuter du sujet aujourd'hui à
l'émission vous connaissez la tradition
pour découvrir le sujet on regarde la
vidéo tous ensemble cinq images dès que
vous sentez être sur la piste du sujet
aujourd'hui vous vous prononcez on
regarde
alors jusque là à l'enfant
concentration
de l'attention
donc c'est hyperactivité ou
ça voici la réponse dans le mot et de
chercher
en espagnol c'est un problème mondial ça
c'est en français voilà alors
hyperactivité tous les enfants souffrant
des par activités enfin il y a des
problèmes de diagnostic c'est qu'on va
essayer de déterminer ensemble qu'est-ce
qui se passe avec nos enfants moi je
vais vous faire une confession quand
j'étais
adolescent ma mère me disait que j'étais
hyperactif et elle avait consulté un
spécialiste pour voir si j'avais pas
besoin de quelque chose pour me casser
et puis même à l'âge adulte vous voyez
j'ai encore des problèmes
oui on se pose tous des questions
parfois
la vérité sort de la bouche des enfants
alors voici c'est donc le sujet
aujourd'hui je vous inviter maintenant à
répondre à notre première question c'est
le jeu de la boule 3 joueurs à chaque
émission sans vous la perdre pour le
premier jeu 20 boules à perdre et après
ça on va vers notre spécialiste de la
question
donc on compte sur toi Bernard alors
voici la dictée
voici le nombre de diagnostics de T a e
t a bon Dieu TDAH
et plus élevé dit-on en Amérique du Nord
mais ça varie beaucoup d'un pays à
l'autre de d'une région à l'autre du
monde il y a des diagnostics dans
certaines régions du monde on dit mon du
temps d'enfants ils sont il y en a
beaucoup dans d'autres nations du Nord
dans les pays occidentaux dans
l'ensemble sur 100 enfants combien en
moyenne
présenteraient des symptômes de la
TDAH
trois enfants sur cinq
des cinq enfants sur 100 c'est 11
enfants sur 100 dans les pays
occidentaux ou encore le fameux d aucune
de ces réponses
[Musique]
sur Oui on parle de surdiagnostic ou des
choses qu'on rentre quand on va aller
sur ça
à la caméra parce que vous faites partie
de l'équipe
alors 3C à l'examen je voudrais trois
trois un parce que c'est des mauvaises
réponses en fait c'est A et B moi
j'aurais accepté de réponse A et B ces
trois enfants sur ça ou cinq enfants sur
ça
statistiques ça on peut jouer avec les
statistiques vraiment savoir c'est quoi
la situation au Canada creuser l'affaire
c'est pour ça que dans ce genre
d'histoire on a besoin d'un spécialiste
et c'est tout un spécialiste on va
d'abord regarder la vidéo numéro 2 pour
découvrir qu'il est il s'agit du docteur
falardeaughi Falardeau et il a écrit un
tout nouveau livre paru je pense c'est
l'automne dernier tout ce qui bouge
n'est pas
TDA que j'aime bien ça c'est magnifique
comme titre je vous aime beaucoup tout
sourient et puis on en a beaucoup parlé
à l'antenne de Radio-Canada parce que il
fait partie aussi d'un groupe de
médecins 48 médecins qui ont dénoncé la
surdmédicalisation les mauvais
diagnostics entourant cette c'est cet
ensemble de maladies que l'on met sous
l'acronyme TDAH on va prendre des choses
moins c'est pour ça que j'aime beaucoup
aborder ce genre de sujets c'est que
j'apprends en même temps que vous adapté
à Falardeau bonjour
vous êtes dans la région de Charlevoix
au Québec vous nous entendez bien
moi je vous entends très bien vous comme
ils étaient à côté
c'est bien gentil de participer à
l'émission en faisant en regardant tous
les points de vue sur cette question là
votre nom revient tout le temps ça fait
43 ans que vous intéressez à cette
question de près et de loin
ça fait 43 ans que je pratique et oui je
me suis toujours intéressé même quand
j'étais étudiant quel est le pourcentage
peut-être de vos jeunes patients qui
dont les symptômes sont reliés à cette à
ce syndrome moi cette maladie
contre 4.2% dans le reste du Canada et
plus récemment l'ISQ institut de la
statistique du Québec on est pas loin de
20% selon si on questionne les jeunes du
secondaire autour de 20 % 10 prend des
médicaments pour le TDAH donc on trouve
que ça pédaleure qu'on a un gros
problème de société et on veut trouver
des solutions et on interpelle les
politiciens on veut que les ministres
fassent quelque chose on veut en fait on
demande une réunion de tous les experts
au Québec pour essayer de trouver une
solution à ce problème il y a plusieurs
choses dans ce que vous venez de dire il
y a le pourcentage au Canada anglais
enfin le reste du pays 4,6% je pense et
20% selon la dernière statistique se
déroule d'écart en réalité les vrais au
niveau des du nombre de jeunes là qui
souffriraient du problème ce serait quel
pourcentage selon votre expérience à
vous
on lit toutes sortes de statistiques la
Société canadienne de pédiatrie dit 3.5%
d'autres disent autour de 7 à 8% moi je
pense que les Québécois on est un peuple
créatif et que les créatifs ont souvent
plus de TDAH donc qu'on est en 7 et 10%
au Québec ça serait probablement normal
mais rendu à 15 ou 20%, il y a du sur
diagnostic et surtout c'est que en
bureau on voit des enfants souffrants
qui ont définitivement des problèmes
autres que le TDAH mais qui se font
diagnostiquer pour toutes sortes de
raisons et c'est ce qu'on veut éviter
parce que souvent c'est des enfants
anxieux qui sont agités à cause de leur
anxiété qui sont inattentifs à cause de
leur anxiété et les médicaments
temporairement les uns donc on s'occupe
pas de leur anxiété et tout à coup tout
explose après six mois un an on change
de médicaments ça vaut pas mieux et en
fait l'erreur c'est d'avoir donné des
médicaments
mais comme personne veut s'occuper de
l'anxiété des enfants ou en tout cas
c'est très difficile de d'amener les les
CLSC les pédopsychiatres s'occuper de
l'anxiété des enfants on est obligé de
donner des médicaments et on veut plus
donner des médicaments aux enfants qui
ont pas de TDAH est-ce qu'il y a
beaucoup des enfants qui ont TDAH
beaucoup des adultes qui ont moins de
patience
comment on définit le TDAH parce que
ma femme est orthophoniste puis vraiment
en face de ces problématiques tous les
jours puis les premières reflets des
enseignants se dire oh c'est improbable
de TDAH
et puis envoyer ça au médecin puis
finalement c'est comme on sait pas mais
l'enfant il termine mais avec la
médication alors c'est quoi le problème
c'est comme comme société on a un
problème que moi je me rappelle quand
j'étais petit moi j'étais vraiment
TDAH plus plus plus mais maintenant
c'est comme que on n'a pas la capacité
de contenir les enfants de
les accompagner c'est une problème de
notre système scolaire c'est une
problème comme société
c'est un problème très complexe oui le
système scolaire est moins patient
surtout permet moins aux garçons à trop
de bouger en permets moins il y a une
école récemment qui a instauré dans sa
cour d'école un endroit où les enfants
pouvaient se pousser pouvaient se lutter
et c'est devenu un phénomène mais quand
on était en fin c'était la norme alors
les garçons ont besoin de bouger ont
besoin de de jeux un peu rude et on leur
permet tout ça en fait les écoles sont
gérées désolé de le dire par des femmes
et ils sont désespérés pour les filles
plus que pour les garçons et les garçons
ben ont de la misère à gérer leurs
besoins de bouger c'est une des
explications la deuxième c'est qu'il y a
beaucoup beaucoup d'enfants anxieux pour
toutes sortes de raisons entre autres
les séparations des parents entre autres
tout ce qui voit aux nouvelles qui qui
fait que l'avenir est peut-être moins
rassurant au niveau de l'environnement
etc tous ces tout ça fait que l'anxiété
augmente l'anxiété fait que les enfants
sont plus agités et on essaie de les
calmer avec des médicaments pour TDAH
Paloma puis ensuite Samir
cette lettre là mais les reste des
experts au Québec est-ce qu'ils sont
répondus est-ce qu'ils sont réagis
comment ça a été la réponse en fait
il y en a beaucoup qui ont appuyé qui
ont dit qu'il aurait signé en fait on
n'a pas demandé à tout le monde si vous
voulez signer on était quatre on a
préparé une lettre et à la dernière
minute il y en a un des quatre qui a
demandé à d'autres médias si vous voulez
nous appuyer et c'est comme ça qu'on
s'est retrouvé une quarantaine 48 mais
c'est pas 48 sur en fait la seule
réponse négative a été
matondie à l'Hôpital Sainte-Justine mais
il faut comprendre que les spécialistes
d'abord le taux de médication à Montréal
est beaucoup plus bas que dans le reste
de la province et un médecin qui
travaille à Sainte Justine avec des
orthophonistes avec des psychiatres et
des psychologues en pour la même
pratique que nous en région où on a
aucune aide aucun soutien ou ça prend
six mois un an avant qu'un enfant voit
psychologue à travers social donc on est
obligé de faire quelque chose et c'est
et c'est ce qu'on dénonçait les les
pédiatres pratiquent à Sainte Justine
n'ont pas du tout ce problème là je
voulais rebondir sur la même question
mais est-ce que vous votre appel à
trouver écho auprès des politiciens
est-ce que vous avez eu quelques des
réponses est-ce que ce que vous avez vu
que les hommes ou les femmes politiques
ont été sensibles à votre appel
le docteur karma qui est ministre
délégué de la santé
oh profitez de notre appel pour annoncer
de l'aide pour les Petits Prés scolaires
maintenant nous on veut qu'il se
prononce pour les plus vieux aux
dernières nouvelles il y a simplement
dit que il s'en occupait mais c'est
notre intention maintenant le groupe des
quatre c'est de pousser plus loin et de
demander des comptes aux politiciens
ministre l'éducation ministre de la
Santé et ministre délégale à la santé
d'accord ce que je peux
docteur Falardeau par rapport au
surdiagnostic vous avez signalé la
différence entre fille et garçon est-ce
qu'en ce moment il y a plus de le sur
diagnostic il est plus poussé chez les
garçons que chez les filles c'est ça si
je comprends bien en fait l'étude de
l'ISQ où ils ont demandé aux jeunes
avez-vous un diagnostic les gens du
secondaire c'était 27% des garçons qui
disaient qu'il y avait un diagnostic de
TDAH au secondaire au Québec en
2016-2017 contre 18% des filles dans nos
bureaux ça semble plus le vexer mais il
y a un certain nombre aussi de filles
qui consulte plus pour gagner attention
moins pour de l'agitation et qui se font
prescrire des médicaments mais oui il y
a plus de garçons que de filles qui ont
des diagnostics parce que il y a une
distinction à faire entre TDA et TDAH
en fait aux dernières nouvelles en
français TDAH ça n'existe pas parce que
TDAH trouve des citadres d'attention
avec ou sans hyperactivité
donc probablement qu'on devrait faire la
même chose au Québec mais pour le moment
à ma connaissance c'est pas
officiellement accepté mais oui il y a
ceux qui ont l'agitation et ceux qui en
ont pas en fait c'est ceux qui ont de
l'impulsivité parce qu'ils sont agitées
c'est normal
avoir de l'énergie c'est normal mais ne
pas être capable de gérer son besoin de
bouger c'est ça qui est le TDAH
qu'est-ce qui pose problème est-ce que
c'est le surdiagnostic ou c'est la
médication est-ce qu'il y a pas autre
solution que la médication par rapport à
quelqu'un qui est diagnostiqué oui il y
a d'autres solutions mais les autres on
peut pas les appliquer puis ceux qui
devraient les appliquer refusent
systématiquement de le faire et le
problème du surdiagnostic c'est que j'ai
vu ce matin à mon bureau une adolescente
maintenant j'ai de 17 ans qui
en la voyant je réalise que c'était
probablement faut diagnostic et
aujourd'hui est pris avec un problème
d'anxiété très difficile à gérer
peut-être que si on l'avait bien
diagnostiqué il y a 10 ans peut-être
qu'on aurait vu son anxiété et qu'on
l'aurait traité et qu'elle aurait pas ce
problème là aujourd'hui il y a des
beaucoup d'enfants autistes qui
sont mal diagnostiqués TDAH et qu'on
s'occupe pas de leur vraie besoin parce
qu'on n'a pas le vrai diagnostic
comment comment on peut bien
diagnostiquer alors quels sont les
étapes à suivre c'est un parent ça
demande est-ce que mon enfant a un
problème ou non donc comment on fait
pour bien diagnostiquer
quels sont où aller c'est le gros
problème justement parce que les gens
s'entendent pas exemple la Société
canadienne de pédiatrie prend le même il
y a cadran aussi un groupe canadien aux
autres c'est on fait des questionnaires
et on Jasse pendant deux trois heures
avec les parents et l'enfant et
finalement on va selon notre pif nous
autres on aimeraient bien évaluation
objective où on fait des tests
d'attention à la fin et surtout on
vérifie si l'enfant est anxieux on
vérifie s'il y a d'autres problèmes et
on aimerait ça avoir des tests objectifs
et c'est une des choses pour lesquelles
on veut une réunion
de tous les de tous les experts
québécois pour s'entendre justement sur
comment on fait le diagnostic
un studio ici parce que j'aimerais que
notre webmestre propose la vidéo numéro
3 pour accompagner les propos et je
pense que ça porte sur la médication ou
sur les sur les enfants sur des tests
qui sont effectués c'est des images
tournées par Radio-Canada ou vous avez
eu une spécialiste qui regarde un enfant
à travers une fenêtre
ça s'en vient oui
je pense que ça c'est ça se passe au
Québec c'est ça alors là vous voyez les
enfants qui sont peut-être des problèmes
de comportement en classe on a tous vécu
ça on est passé par là où on avait de
discuté à rester assis à son à son siège
et l'enseignant qui devient irrité oui
parce que ça nous arrive ne passait par
là vous qu'est-ce que vous aviez des
comportements moi j'étais toute seule
peut-être l'anxiété aussi mais j'ai pas
eu en fait à ce temps-là on parlait pas
de médication je sais pas moi j'étais
très chanceuse parce que j'allais dans
une école alternative c'était pas appelé
alternatif de l'école active c'était
très en Mexique on a cette notion de
l'école de l'éducation active donc c'est
une école dans laquelle on mettait de
l'accent sur le bout l'effet de bouger
les faire l'effet de se déplacer dans la
classe le fait d'aller parler aux
professeurs plusieurs fois on avait
vraiment pas de restrictions des
mouvements et je pense que ça fait en
sorte que je suis quelqu'un d'épanoui
aujourd'hui
parce que j'ai beaucoup d'énergie donc
j'aurais été probablement très mal et je
remarque dans vos personnalités donc je
fais pas mon métier sur la question de
l'anxiété le lien entre le la maladie et
l'anxiété est-ce que l'anxiété toujours
présente un moment donné l'enfant
s'aperçoit qu'il ne peut pas
il a pas le bon comportement au bon
endroit et est-ce que c'est ça qui j'ai
qui fait tourner la roue de l'anxiété où
il y a des cas où il y a pas d'anxiété
il y a simplement un enfant qui n'a
aucune qui n'a pas conscience que il ne
performe pas aussi facilement aussi bien
qu'il pourrait s'il était aidé
le TDAH c'est un phénomène neurologique
qui donne des symptômes et oui à la
longue l'enfant peut être anxieux mais
quand la fin est anxieux à 4 ans c'est
pas à cause d'un TDAH le vidéo vous avez
passé montre justement comment faire un
mauvais diagnostic je m'excuse c'est à
dire qu'on se base seulement sur le
comportement de l'enfant et qu'on ne
recherche pas la source du comportement
cette enfant-là qui était agité qu'il y
a des comportements
quoi il a ses comportements-là et c'est
ça qu'il faut qu'on se pose comme
question est-ce que il y a pas manger ce
midi est-ce que il y a des problèmes ses
parents ont des problèmes est-ce que
c'est un enfant qui a été maltraité
est-ce que c'est un enfant qui était
abusé est-ce que c'est un enfant qui est
anxieux on sait rien de ça et c'est ça
le problème c'est qu'on regarde des
symptômes on coche et on dit voilà c'est
un TDAH parce qu'il a les symptômes mais
non parce que il faut regarder la cause
des symptômes et c'est ça qu'on dénonce
je vous dis qu'on vient d'avoir une
leçon aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'on peut passer ces vidéos
comme obligatoire dans les écoles
[Musique]
du côté des diagnostics de façon
générale d'après notre spécialiste ce
n'est pas évident non
diagnostic mieux est-ce qu'on fait des
comme vous dites des diagnostics plus
objectif ou c'est comme ça partout dans
le monde
je sais pas en principe aux États-Unis
c'est eux qui ont établi les critères de
diagnostic il devrait faire un meilleur
travail mais je sais pas il y a des
endroits à Québec au Québec où on fait
des bons diagnostics il y a des
neuropsychologues au Québec qui font des
bons diagnostics mais c'est plus
l'exception que la règle et c'est très
complexe une bonne évaluation dans le
privé ça coûte environ 2000 dollars aux
parents c'est pas tous les parents qui
ont 2000 dollars donc ils prennent les
évaluations à 1000 dollars qui sont des
évaluations ou justement on s'attarde
seulement sur les symptômes et on pose
des diagnostics sans avoir vraiment
regardé la cause des symptômes
je pense que vous êtes sur une histoire
où il faut absolument que les gens
s'informent parce que ça moi je
regardais ces images du diagnostic en
disant bon c'est scientifique c'est
pas l'air du tout d'être ça on est tous
passé par des petits des petits moments
de
d'hyperactivité là où on a failli se
faire passer moi c'est évident alors
écoutez merci beaucoup docteur d'avoir
participé l'émission d'autant plus vous
aviez vous aviez un mal le mal du siècle
mal de l'hiver un petit peu avec la
gorge c'était pas évident
c'est moi qui vous remercie c'est nous
qui vous remercions merci infiniment
merci beaucoup alors c'était le docteur
Falardeau pédiatre à Québec si vous
cherchez un spécialiste pour vous aider
il connaît il a aussi des collègues qui
peuvent faire le bon travail donc vous
appelez le bureau je suis sûr qu'ils
vont faire des vont vous référer à
quelqu'un d'autre si le docteur
Falardeau qui est à la préretraite ne
peut pas s'occuper de ce que la
précisément moi on a pris beaucoup de
choses je vais vous montrer la vidéo
numéro 4 et je peux pas faire cette
seule
[Musique]
mais du côté Barcelone
c'est très bien mais voilà vous êtes un
spécial je devrais être à la télévision
[Rires]
de participer avec tout ce qu'on appelle
pilule dans les pharmacies pour les
enfants les images encore une fois c'est
absolument pour les enfants non
là ça manque comment la médicament
Ritalin peut fonctionner
ça fonctionne dans certains cas c'est
nécessaire il y a pas d'admission
mais bon on va se document justement
c'est que je passe c'est que il y a
beaucoup de gens qui prend ça puisqu'ils
devaient pas les prendre alors est-ce
que les problèmes quand ils vont être
plus grand ça va être plus grand
à cause que dans ce moment donné dans sa
vie ils ont fait ça non si vous avez
écrit le script de l'émission
aujourd'hui deuxième tour la grosse
boule
j'ai la réponse pour vous merci beaucoup
c'est la deuxième question
combien de points à perdre pour ce
deuxième tour de la grande
partez déjà avec 80 on va faire
attention
à l'écran pour qu'on sente votre
présence voilà votre elle rayonne sur
nous regardez comme ça
alors les symptômes de la TDAH
peuvent persister à l'âge adulte oh oui
comme ils le disait selon vous quel
pourcentage sur 100 enfants là
aujourd'hui qui ont ce problème
mais qui devient l'adulte vont encore
vont toujours manifester des sur les 7%
là où sur les 7%
qu'il y a 100 enfants qui appartiennent
au groupe de
ils vont grandir un jour on l'espère
devient ils arrivent à l'âge adulte
alors sur ces 100 ex jeunes enfants
est-ce que c'est déjà compris des
médicaments ah oui ok
16 jeune adulte sur 100 26
sur 56 sur 100 ou encore le fameux d
aucune 16
[Musique]
la bonne réponse si vous avez qui a
répondu aucune de ces réponses face à
personne c'est dommage de tous perdu 30
€
jusqu'à 66 % les deux tiers c'est à dire
qu'on reconnaît qu'un tiers d'entre eux
vont éliminer complètement les symptômes
et les autres il y en a qui vont
conserver certains symptômes donc guéris
est-ce qu'on va arrêter avec apparemment
le tiers il est il a toujours des
séquelles des problèmes à l'âge adulte
il y a encore un tiers mais il y a deux
tiers qui pour qui ça a été un combat
passé l'enfance et on dit que c'est
même mal connu
c'est encore une fois contre l'autisme
je pense qu'il est chez la butte il est
un peu mieux c'est la mission spéciale
là-dessus un peu plus d'un an et
peut-être qu'on pourrait l'ajouter en
complément d'information c'était
exactement le même genre de monde où les
choses sont mal diagnostiquées ou c'est
complètement renversant de voir ce que
ce qui se passe au niveau de notre
mécompréhension des maladies qui sont de
problème sont largement répandus mais
peut-être moins on le pense sont surtout
mal diagnostiqués on va faire une petite
pause parce que là vous avez perdu
beaucoup de points je pense
que vous avez perdu beaucoup d'or
aujourd'hui n'est-ce pas on va garder
l'argent on va garder l'argent alors on
va aller vers la découverte Marie-Claude
vous réapparaissait l'antenne vous
devriez rester avec nous tout le long
terme
alors écoutez c'est deviner l'image de
la semaine d'accord on a une petite
musique normalement d'accompagnement
pour vous stresser un peu ah pas pour
nous aider
alors moi je réponds par oui ou par
moment à vos questions quelle est
l'image de cette au Canada ça s'est
passé au Canada oui OK
je réponds seulement par où pardon
[Musique]
[Rires]
qui vivaient dans l'esclavage
le verdict
[Musique]
mais vous êtes toujours sur la bonne
piste
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avant ah oui
apparemment deux chaises moi j'ai vu une
version elle avait lancé deux chaises
deux petites chaises voilà mais c'était
quoi le challenge ici c'est juste comme
ça elle était fâché la chaise
un peu samedi soir donc ça c'est le
lendemain
là là ça change
venez nous voir parce que le public
la police avait demandé l'aide du public
à 19 ans comme ça qu'elle va changer de
comportement
[Rires]
des travaux communautaires est-ce que ce
sera dans son cadeau prison à vie oui
oui si ça c'est reconnue coupable prison
à vie
ok
sur la sur la un accident qui aurait
entraîné la mort de plusieurs personnes
aussi c'est pas juste
pourquoi je sais pas peut-être un moment
YouTube
on y va pour le dernier jeu
troisième tour combien de points à
perdre 50 alors
est-ce qu'on peut ne pas participer
ça fait beaucoup de peine je pense quand
je prépare ces questions là j'ai dit
faux faut que je sois j'ai beaucoup
d'empathie pour eux parce que des fois
réponse
ok alors c'est pour toujours sur sur les
drogues OK
ou la Ritaline là qu'on donne aux
enfants nécessairement qui qui ont le
problème de TDAH mais la Ritalin est
utilisée aussi par des adultes des
étudiants qui veulent rester éveillés
les étudiants utilisent aujourd'hui
[Musique]
merci pour merci
vous
voyez pas aux étudiants quel pourcentage
des étudiants en médecine au Canada ah
là c'est là selon une estimation du
Journal de l'Association médicale
canadienne utilise ce qu'on appelle la
Ritaline il y a d'autres il y a d'autres
médicaments je vous ai parlé non mais
des nous comme on appelle ça quelque
chose
est-ce que c'est à 5% des étudiants en
médecine mais c'est encore
où est-ce que c'est c'est
55%, je suis mon cœur balance entre 55
et 35
35% 35%
ah et bien vous avez tous raison c'est
de 5 à
35%, c'est c'est énorme
parce qu'ils connaissent leur molécule
tout ça donc c'est bien
je trouve que c'est eux qui vont
provoque les mêmes diagnostiqués à
l'avenir
mais il faut il faut qu'il qu'il
commence
ah oui il faut qu'il teste leurs preuves
[Musique]
en Angleterre il y a une enquête
récemment qui disait que 20 % de tous
les étudiants peu importe son permis de
nous on utilise à l'occasion pas tout le
temps alors mais dis à vous avoir déjà
une procrastine puis à la dernière
Royaume-Uni j'ai pas vu d'enquête au
Canada ça sera un bon sujet d'enquête
absolument ouais alors écoutez pas
oublier on termine l'émission là-dessus
c'est notre vidéo numéro 6 quel chiffre
chanceux c'est la vidéo sur
l'application qui permet de regarder
l'écouter regardez maintenant nos
émissions et nous produits RCI en cinq
langues il paraît que 30 personnes par
jour uniquement du côté français on
diffuse nous en 5 langues qui télécharge
l'application c'est un record du côté de
l'application version française
sur Google Play radio
français et S pour l'espagnol et n pour
anglais à air pour la lave ZH pour les
Chinois et puis ru pour la Russie
ça nous prend sur 30 à chaque émission
quand même
jouer à House of Cards et décréter
l'état d'urgence merci
[Rires]
beaucoup Marie-Claude vous réapparaisser
l'équipe tout le monde réapparaît comme
ça on est capable d'avoir un plan
d'ensemble voilà c'est tout pour cette
semaine à la semaine prochaine tout le
monde
[Musique]